I almost wore my thank you for not
overacting t-shirt today and that is
should I market that should I can we can
we go in on it together but going back
to that um I've read that since becoming
a director you sort of have taken the
onus off yourself as an actor that you
don't have to tell the whole story or
over act in this character you could
totally have gone there yeah that's
actually that's true it's something that
I've learned from being a director is
that like you don't to not feel as
though with your performance you have to
tell the whole story that the directors
got a lot of means at his disposal with
which he's telling the story and you
just need to maintain stay true to the
integrity of what your character isn't
would be doing and if all things are
working right the script and the
director are are telling the story all
around you and you can ride that
momentum I definitely became a better
actor and I was started erecting for
sure but it's always about the cat you
know it's just always about the
character and the story work making sure
we're telling the same story and what's
the intention of the scene and what the
character wants so you know we try
things that like I don't know let's try
we'll see if it works so there's a
safety there then you just explore
together you have one scene that really
stood out to me in the film do you
approach that moment differently than
other scenes do you go I know this is
gonna be something I really got a hit or
is it consistent hopefully it's
consistent I mean I try to keep it
consistent i mean the the moments that i
think a lot of actors relish or enjoy
more look forward to are those the
moments that are that are maybe a
departure for that particular character
or the moments of vulnerability or
volatility you know what would you do
about volatility yeah it was almost like
watching a great actor do a monologue
and sort of you know unravel this story
and really it's sort of that you know
acting is reacting type of thing it was
a lot of just sort of taking in what he
was saying and connecting the dots
there's that scene that I call it kind
of like the Jackson Pollock math scene
where you're writing all these numbers
on the wall that's sort of like the
reveal of his his gift and I read that
you like and it or you approach that
scene with like these great athletes
like your boy Tom Brady in mind
somebody's always this
done with excellence like I'm ready it's
now four or he's job I would that I
could be this greatest I'm ready but
Christian was really good at math like
McGavin put together this sequence which
was were just trying to help illustrate
to the audience like take the inside of
his brain and show it to an audience you
know projected on a screen and it was
fun to be part of that and to try to you
know make that town tangible to people
so who is he do you count like a CPA
akum not quite
you